hello and welcome to honest trailer
commentaries we're gonna move this along
quickly because JT's got to beat the
rain traffic
I'm star Dan Morello and we're here to
talk about one thing and that is
Danzig's song moto now we're talking
about something equally obscure which is
the Darren Aronofsky film mother mother
mother with the exclamation point
we'll be watching along with you on our
Australian giving some behind the scenes
look and if you stick around till the
end you'll see some cut jokes maybe some
deleted scenes out this time okay I
always look to Dan yeah tell me what's
happening he would know well got child
but before we begin let's just what
didn't go into the video that we thought
about mother surprise that this was the
number for choice
yeah of our fans who voted I think they
just wanted to challenge us so I thank
you actually this is much more
interesting than doing one for some of
the other options might have been yeah
thank you another pirates movie or
something Eric thing my my pure disdain
for this movie didn't make it in because
i rage wrote you a draft of this trailer
and yeah alright this was one where well
i have to say it kind of like mother i
didn't hate it i did not i know you guys
really neither be really liked the movie
at all and i get why people would hate
this film i didn't hate it i won't
begrudge you your enjoyment of it it got
so insane that i was like how could you
hate this it's insane it was not a pure
visual level of like what is happening i
enjoy that kind of thing i didn't hate
it it wasn't for me
it's not for me enjoy i I don't know I
just twenty minutes in you're like I get
it and then see I just ignored I'm a
little slow I'm less schooled in the New
Testament then perhaps others this table
I did not get I was trying to wrap my
head around like what does this
symbolize even though when someone told
me oh it's the Bible is like
that's because he's the now I get it but
I didn't get that throughout the whole I
think even if I hadn't been like Bible I
think I still we took a lunch break at
some point in watching this film and you
were like do you get to the burning wall
in the basement or whatever yet no like
yeah I just watched it and you were like
it doesn't matter and that was kind of
this whole movie was just stuff really
deep stuff I don't know it just felt
like the annoying guy at college film
school movie well it's fair that vibe
that he gives off it's a you can't have
it both ways because the critters of
this movie is one that it doesn't make
any sense and to that it's so on the
nose you can't have it both ways you
can't be like I don't know this is
random and pointless and then also be
like it's so obvious what he's trying to
say it's got to be one of the other if
you don't know my whole issue this movie
was never I don't get it it was I get it
okay yeah like that's what I came out
like walk coming out I was just like I
get it I think it's a something you know
new there's nothing but yeah that was
the thing for me there's nothing
particularly profound about it it seemed
like he was very very proud of what he
thought was this intricately complex
tale of what I interpreted to be fairly
obvious points that I'm like yeah I
think you think there's more there than
is actually there before everyone labels
us Darren offski haters know is like my
favorite comic book movie what NOAA's
meticulous like know is just a fun
stupid action blockbuster and I love it
and obviously I saw requiem for a dream
in college and was like that's what
movies is and I like a lot of ton of
daring there is great the wrestler is
great Noah is a comic book Bible I love
it there's giant rock monsters in it yes
a great movie this is a I always I said
this often is people say like oh you're
anti artist now not but it's rare that
there is a director of any level of
talent
that should be allowed to do whatever
they want like it rarely ends well live
like a movie that's just like oh we let
him do everything that he wanted with no
other voice or kind of guiding hand it's
called lady in the one yeah well the
water this movie I just saw downsizing
which I was like the pain did which I
think the same studio paramount mmm you
could tell gave the reins over to Darren
Aronofsky and Alexander Payne and both
of those movies from you were just like
somebody needed to step in here and say
like listen I get it
however maybe think about this but I
disagree because in certain cases
because I think that yeah you shouldn't
let them do whatever they want when
you're dealing with a blockbuster
something made for mass appeal this this
was a small art movie that got like
somewhere along the line got misdirected
into the general wide horror movie
release category yes which was if this
is just something that you just saw the
festival you'd be like whoa that was
crazy and then like that's what this
movie where this movie belongs is it is
like straight to Netflix and not even
straight to Netflix like a festival
movie I guess I wonder if I would have
liked it if I was not aware of things
like Darren Aronofsky getting up for its
debut and being like I apologize for
what's about to happen to you and like
things like that I went if I didn't know
about things like that before I watched
mother if I would have liked that puts
me off like this is like almost a shock
jock DJ aspect of that of someone being
like I'm about to g-shock you and you
gotta go okay I know and he's dating
Jennifer Lawrence to start and he's got
the scarf addiction there's a lot riding
against the hype had been so negative
surrounding this movie for me walking
into it the f CinemaScore that's the
visceral hatred of it that I was like
well this is gonna be terrible before
Stanley Kubrick get me I will say it is
rare to find a director should be given
cuz I'm just saying not everyone there
is an occasional Cooper's Anika you get
an occasional Kubrick not everyone's
Kubrick and even even Kubrick sometimes
I was like every
in a while over Cooper likes pop their
head in the door gone Stanley Stan come
on stay no every frame of Barry Lyndon
used to be there
he'll three and a half hours all of them
let's watch mother alright mother
JT's he's got a gun all this time in
traffic seventeen ways it's yelling at
us to make it honest trailer for here's
your number for pig you guys are weird
choices from the mind behind requiem for
a dream Black Swan and Noah comes a
gruesome paranoid Bible allegory which
is kind of what you should expect by now
from the mind behind requiem for a green
black swan and Noah mother experienced a
gripping tale about something where this
mother and this guy have some
increasingly bad houseguests leave me
alone you're an arrogant stuff happens
that is the summary for the movie I'm
like IMDB and elsewhere it's like they
have bad houseguests that was it there's
nothing what can you really say beyond
that you really can't I mean even the
trailer like just show like the first 20
minutes of the movie they're like so
that
yeah just like downsizing we're not
being cagey where it's it's unspoiled
belitz like people show up to the house
and bad stuff happens tough happens yes
yeah stuff happens is the biggest
spoiler we could possibly get and stuff
happens to a lady and a man yeah in a
house the Bible because alright keep
going
goes cuckoo bananas not so great we
tried a lot of different music under
this thing Benny Hill always busy Hill
is only
it makes everything better what is going
on dumb movie you're the dumb one stroke
you're intelligent the Bible where
critics perspective a meditation on the
creative process see this is what I like
the movies because I was trying to
figure out what is it about what is it
it's not so much that it's the fact that
every every interpretation about that
that you can make of this movie it was
so blatantly obvious when it was saying
about those things like it what he was
not saying subtle things about any of
these things and he was saying all of
them simultaneously so it was kind of
like somebody explaining five really
simple points to you in the most obtuse
way possible that's kind of a put me off
is like first of all you're saying
twelve different things secondly I get
it
about every one of them it's it's not
like some kind of like deep-seated
allegory about it's like it seemed to me
like six fairly obvious takes on six
different topics all being spoken at
once and it was a yeah you know I to
some people that appealed to them to me
it was just a cacophony of nothingness
and by some people we mean the guys that
still freaked out over the matrix that
are like wait the world might not be
real man like some people adored this
movie that's fine
I just didn't speak to me I wouldn't say
I adore it but I would say that the what
I enjoyed out of it was trying to figure
out what he was saying so I know that
that's like for some it was obvious and
for some it was so broad and bland that
it was saying nothing but friends like
oh is that like is he supposed to be ego
is he supposed to be himself is it like
what what these are clearly like
allegories and they're clearly
archetypes for other things like just
trying to puzzle out what was what like
like staring at a piece of stupid art
that people you know like that people
just do
our blocks in like what do you what do
you see in it so that's what I thought
was interesting about it but that's
great but yeah not everyone can handle
mova keeping uses to answer basic
questions about plot or character but
does tell you what Extreme Home Makeover
would look like if it were directed by
Satan move that
[Music]
[Applause]
right clipart with this who's the tree
that will disturb you to your very core
what was that baby but part of the Bible
is the part in the toilet Kristen Wigg
acting serious
the inspirational and unprepared public
speaking just say something see this is
my actual worst nightmare gimme a follow
jennifer lawrence's it just makes around
for half the run time as she takes on a
non-stop barrage of household chores lot
of that [ __ ] run demands around this is
the best possible flip and stares at the
wall but if that sounds boring wait
until you hear what her husband is going
through he's a poet with writer's block
whoa man this movie sounds like it was
written by a guy with a lot of scarves
oh right so deposit in his defense he
says that that's because he gets a
tickles in his throat a lot I remember I
read the follow-up to like the all the
scarf talk is it's like I don't wrote
he's a sensitive man I think it's like
the you know the scary story to tell in
the dark about the girl at the scar from
the guy marries her and then she found
text and her head falls off
I think that's near near Natsuki I think
something's gonna decide just gonna go
on the set of Noah - oh no fell off okay
well mystery solved yeah mystery solved
it's about the scary Stokes tales in the
dark
so dive into the esoteric film that
audiences either loved hated or releated
in this film that looks and sounds
beautiful is that in the movie that's
mr. antic rosacea he'll never tell you
the audience thing but sometimes feels
like the whole thing was dashed out over
a long weekend because it was
inspiration strikes again take a bunch
of Gurkha uppers and literally register
fire No Country for Old Testaments dread
Flanders caddy woman a McCoy brother
what it feels like to host comedian
sting goes down from there that sinks
not race to get down from there well
that's good they caused the Biblical
Flood that's the no apart I got that
wonderful by the water wedding into the
house
Big Momma's House three yeah there's one
thing you can count on in the movie it's
that a writer working in isolation will
always go insane yep that's true in life
and in film all right guys we're
mothered we mothered there's more we
mother together so let's see what got
cut from prepare for a movie that was
tailor-made to be hated as this art
house film was sold as a straight-up
horror flick nationwide release instead
of a slow roll out and hit theaters just
one week after everyone saw it not a
great plan hello Tony story a poet and
he knows it
the venom
back what general Fox yes Batman
randomly losses for your mind that goes
by really quick like too quick to
process but do explain damn ya know
there's a world there's there's an
alternate reality outside of our own
we're in darren aronofsky directed
potentially to comic book movies
Wolverine and Batman whoa so he could
have taken this kind of weird Nolan II
path of like the indie director that
went into the blockbusters so this is
weird to think about like him doing that
and then doing this so it's like you
know it's like if Christopher Nolan
released this batshit crazy no pun
intended
thing of just like yeah I often like I
wish I could kind of I mean every more
anything and like watch the Darren
Aronofsky Batman year one yeah or his
his Wolverine would be it would have
been Logan before Logan I mean yeah was
to give the wrestler claws and like yeah
you got it
yeah yeah so III wonder what that would
have been like if he had kind of taken
that side road of like the mainstream
then where does Nolan go no one just
keeps making like insomnia level budget
films which I'm listing yeah real weird
world three-piece suits yes or or
Aronofsky wears the three-piece suits
and Nolan wears this well that's all the
analysis I've got from other anything
else said yes no movie yeah weird ass
movie that some people like not for me
but whatever I'm thank you for voting
for it because it was at least
interesting to do exactly I would say I
didn't love it but but give it a shot
because it will provoke you one way or
the other and I'll take that over
blendness
any day yes sir yeah you said it sir and
we'll be back next week where we're
gonna talk about something else scary
but maybe maybe already seen it maybe
you've already seen it and what we just
yeah
I see what you did yeah anyways uh damn
Merle Joestar especially a Gilbert we'll
see you next week Mike
[Music]
you